let's do a small thought experiment
let's teleport in the future and
encounter the reality of what is known
there as an experienced machine imagine
that technology has reached the point
where this machine could stimulate your
brain in such a way that you could
experience anything you desire all you
need to do is enter a floating tank and
attach a bunch of electrodes to your
head however the technology of the
machine is developed in such a way that
once you plug yourself in the machine
you can't unplug of course so while in
the tank you won't know that you're
there you'll think that it's all
actually happening would you go for it
would you plug into this machine for
life pre-programming your life
experiences knowing that there is no way
back
this interesting thought experiment was
suggested by philosopher nobert nozick
in his book anarchy state and utopia in
1974. nozick was notorious for his
ability to challenge conventional wisdom
and come up with contrarian ideas that
could tantalize one's reality the point
raised via the experience machine is
whether or not hedonism should be
regarded as the most valuable human
pursuit our proclivity to avoid pain
embrace paths of least resistance and
easily accept pleasure
wherever it comes from presupposes that
for most the experience machine would
sound like a good deal nozick however
believed that pleasure is not the only
intrinsic value and that although one
could go about experiencing life by a
pleasure seeking philosophy pleasure
shouldn't be treated as an end but
rather as a means to an end regardless
of whether or not you would go for the
experience machine
our relationship with pleasure is rather
weird sometimes even quite absurd we all
have experienced at some point in our
lives the aftermath of our pleasure
seeking tendencies it could be that the
brain cannot keep up with the production
of serotonin dopamine and endorphins
that seek to glorify the sensation of a
certain experience it could be that we
grow tired of the lack of novelty
entailed in a certain activity habit or
relationship it could be that ideas
notions and theories that were
previously regarded as pleasurable now
seem more like a hindrance to our
current state but isn't this kind of
absurd the very drive that you have to
seek pleasure can morph into a
self-destructive force reality is
inundated with such contradictions and
this absurd landscape leads to
questioning the very meaning of
existence and it also creates bizarre
living conditions for everyone partaking
in it this is more or less how the idea
of absurdism came about existentialist
philosophers like soren kirkergaard or
albert camus kept bumping into
predicaments that illustrated the
conflict between the human desire to
seek inherent value and meaning in life
and the human inability to actually
discover this with any certainty the
absurd is an omnipresent condition
throughout the human experience
absurdism encompasses everything related
to the fundamental disharmony between
the individual's search for meaning and
the seeming meaninglessness of the
cosmos in such a landscape one has
usually two options either allow
absurdism to devour them and lose touch
with meaning or confront the absurd by
developing their own existentialist
philosophy and today i will reveal some
aspects of my existentialist philosophy
indulge
familiarizing ourselves with the way our
brain operates can lead to marvelous
ways to manage it but also improve the
way we evolve our thinking motifs
although more information grants us
access to more knowledge our ability to
analyze this information is predicated
upon our ability to understand our
cerebral makeup think of your brain as
an uber sensitive tool that shapes its
form and capacity in accordance with the
information it gathers nowadays the
information torrent we have to face has
increased dramatically and our brain
struggles to keep up with this new
reality instances of people who feel
confused and don't know what to do with
all this information keep cropping up
you can see that most are lost in their
thoughts and find it quite challenging
to structure a well-articulated stream
of reasoning the verdict is that we
weren't ready to deal with this
predicament ergo the adoption of
methodologies relative to the taming of
our brain becomes imperative instead of
going adrift and allowing technology to
hijack our mind leading to a future
attention war dystopia each one of us
has the option to abstract it we
obstruct it through meditation reading
writing expressing ourselves creatively
we obstruct it by transitioning from
consumers to creators that's one of the
main reasons i started this channel i
realized that this was the only sure way
i could tame my mind
this was the only sure way to stay sane
discussing the ramifications of a rat
race driven reality is one of my
favorite topics
i do that very consciously for i feel
that the more i reduce its significance
the more i allow myself to disengage
from it the rat race despite how we end
up portraying it as a noteworthy use we
tend to ignore adaptation and blending
in is an integral component of our
constitution the fact that we need to
keep up with a certain race or pursuit
is felt in the bodily sensation we
experience whenever we think that we are
left behind that has both a bad and a
good use a race is just a race choosing
our race will determine the quality of
our life keeping up with the joneses and
keeping up with great contemporary
thinkers can't be seen in the same light
the selection of our opponent so to
speak molds the fabric of our reality
throughout this process the best way to
determine whether or not you are in the
right race is to listen to your body
professor jordan peterson proposed an
interesting exercise in that respect
while you go about experiencing your
life
try and pay attention to how your body
reacts to the things you say and hear
listen to the words you utter and try to
estimate whether or not what you say
feels right and if it makes you feel
solid ask yourself are you subordinating
to something are you hiding from
something if the answer is yes you need
to recalibrate and re-evaluate your
stance living our life that way is how
we cement its authentic nature
as british poets anthony and axagori put
it the sadness of non-authenticity is
lamenting and sitting in the back of
your spirit and every now and then it
taps on the back of your shoulder and
says do something about it the escape
from such a state is crucial and can
only materialize by the process of
listening and recalibration
psychology despite its vastness and the
different schools of thought comprising
it is an extraordinary discipline since
the beginning of the last century and
the establishment of psychology as a
science many pioneers in the field have
proposed their theories and practices
one can get lost in the endless
approaches but at the end of the day
some fundamental principles can allow
one to form a canonical interpretation
of the topic i like to keep things
simple so for me three important tenets
of psychology that everyone should
understand are freud emotions and biases
freud was one of the first to see a
connection between childhood experiences
and behaviors in adults the way you
interacted with various figures in your
family environment has shaped a lot of
your likes habits principles and
neurosis a basic understanding of that
concept can lead to a more healthy and
balanced life people who refuse to see
this connection end up experiencing an
endless circle of emotional suffering
that leads to a toxic life for both them
and their surroundings making
connections to certain events leads to
more awareness and awareness is key when
attempting to escape absurdism
emotions are the most critical drivers
of our actions our emotional world
allows us to add more plurality to our
experiences and connect with others in a
special way however this is both a
blessing and a curse the increasing
intensity of a certain experience can
lead to uncontrolled emotional ups and
downs that shape our reality this can
have detrimental effects on our
well-being since we become fixated on
certain affairs but also become prone to
emotional manipulation
biases blur our attempt to form a more
objective interpretation of reality they
lead to consistent deviations from sound
judgment and can bolster the degree of
unorthodox choices we end up making
biases are the toughest cognitive
process to handle even when one
identifies the existence of a certain
bias the ability to overcome it requires
tremendous awareness and psychological
strength these three tenets need to act
as a ubiquitous error correcting
mechanism that recalibrate problematic
behavioral patterns that feed absurdism
understanding that you might be wrong
despite your intelligence and seemingly
sound beliefs is a significant
constituent of a well-rounded
personality erroneous thinking is all
around us and instances of people who
prefer to exploit it instead of
rectifying it tend to increase
significantly in this perilous landscape
one needs to be careful with how
assumptions are formed and many points
need to be taken into consideration ray
dalio in his podcast with team ferris
suggests that a technique he uses for
capturing the whole picture of an idea
proposition or argument is to consider
the opinion of at least three people
relevant to the topic
by doing that and by capitalizing on his
experience knowledge and intellectual
humility
he ends up adequately informed on a
variety of topics and increases the
possibility of forming a sagacious
judgment on a topic this intellectual
exercise eventually gives rise to the
idea of diversification and the
realization that one can escape
absurdism by attaining a wide array of
knowledge across various disciplines
regardless of how hard you try and
regardless of how much self-awareness
you accrue over the years dark moments
are inevitable especially if you are a
creative and sensitive person your
proclivity towards darkness is going to
affect your world in an intense way once
you recognize that the moment of truth
begins when you stare at the darkness
the darkness stares back at you it is a
momentous instance in your life you
either allow it to own you or you fight
back
there is no middle ground there the
darkness has many forms it can have the
form of a shadow as jung put it it can
have the form of mental and physical
pain it can have the form of depression
and a general disconnection from reality
all these forms signify that one has let
oneself go and surrender to a dark
reality that was imposed on him or her
one way or the other the escape is not
easy a dark reality usually signals a
lack of purpose and an astute lack of
discipline throughout the daily grind
whether we like it or not and we're
purpose-driven beings
purpose is what allows us to add more
structure to our lives and eventually
have control over it purpose can
manifest itself in many ways
it can be an obsession with arts an
attempt to satisfy the need for
self-expression it can be the ambition
to change the world for the better it
can be whatever the individual decides
it to be once you identify your purpose
leave it wholeheartedly create systems
processes goals and protocols around it
find other actors who have similar
purposes and engage with them escape the
banality of abstract living that is
defined by others and assemble your life
around your purpose do that in a
disciplined and if the circumstance
demands it obsessed way that's how you
overcome darkness that's how you escape
absurdism
hey guys hope you enjoyed today's video
if you did make sure to like subscribe
turn on notifications and comment below
something cool please so that more
people can discover it
if you want to watch more videos from my
channel check out this one and this one
take care see you soon editor now